so let's bring us more on that breaking
news that we brought you just a few
moments ago that there's been an
assassination attempt on the former
Pakistani prime minister Imran Khan
let's get the latest then on the phone
I'm joined Now by our Asia correspondent
Cordelia Lynch so Cordelia what can you
tell us
when I'm in wazirabad we were following
Imran Khan on this long march from
Lahore to Islamabad who started this
March six days ago and his Drive uh was
to try and bring early elections to this
country he is pushing her radical change
he was
ousted himself just a short time ago and
we had seen large crowds turning out for
the bank on now I had just interviewed
um the former leader when he I asked him
about the violence that some people have
been concerned about some have predicted
and he was hopeful that they were not
experience planning and that this was a
peaceful March you then went up to the
roof of this container the container is
where he's been addressing the crowds
and it was there after a raucous
reception we had just gone downstairs
inside the container I was speaking to
some of his staff
from the PTI party when we heard a
sudden commotion a man came downstairs
said his foot very bloody
a woman I'd been spoken to suddenly fell
silence there's a lot of concern and
anxiety
then another person came downstairs
clearing the interest they were taken
into an ambulance we were hurried off
the campaign that a lot of panic in the
air people rushing no one could quite
work out what was happening then Imran
Khan
emerge he had been shocked by The Summit
in the left leg in fact our producer
here a Hamid was able to see that he was
very close to Imran Khan as he emerged
he was taken away I've also spoken to
one Doctor Who was close by who has
treated three patients uh they're
clearly the worst case scenario what so
many people were concerned about was
that this peaceful protest had the
potential to turn by now I've spoken to
Imran Khan
soft they insect that he is okay he's
been taken to hospital but there's a
very dramatic kind of events and you
could really feel the rapid fear I
cannot
overestimate just how much of a change
in atmosphere and Tempo that we
witnessed just an hour before we've seen
people throwing up confetti I was being
told by Imran Khan about the momentum
that the genie was out the bottle that
he was confident that he would return to
leadership and then now this which has
I bought a sudden cause uh to what was
meant to be a hateful March for him
and Cordelia just reiterate what we know
about the extent of his injuries then
well I was just able in fact to uh speak
to one of the senior members of his team
she in fact hardly trying to get us into
a car there was obviously worry about
any enduring threats at close by all I
was able to ascertain from her was that
four people were shot including in
mankind in his left leg I asked a
wedding shop had come from because we
had been on top of the container filming
for about an hour and we wanted to
understand whether these shots had been
fired from on top of that container or
not certainly downstairs there was worry
amongst the staff that the threat was on
board that is why we were taking off so
rapidly that in fact there's a senior
member of Staff told us that it had come
from the bizarre area so in other words
the street area surrounding
um this town that we are in this is a a
rural Town one where he enjoys popular
support one of the points being made by
his opponents is that he is going to
Imran Khan territory that he is
addressing uh the devoted if you like so
this will come as a great shock I know a
lot of people within the crowds were
instantly in tears very worried about uh
Imran Khan's house and what had happened
to him at the ambulance has arrived kind
of barrel through the crowd very rapidly
but as I say they were able to remove
him and in fact we too are about to move
on uh to try and get a bit further away
so we can bring you a bit more of this
story as it's unfolding we'll be in
touch with Imran can't please try and
get an update uh on his condition
and give us a sense of why there was
concern about violence surrounding this
long march that you tell us that he was
carrying out give us some context of the
political situation and why there were
concerns that he might be targeted
absolutely well one of I don't have seen
a sort of rhetorical back and forth
between the two sides the the government
with the Murray expressed by the police
and in mankind and his PTI parking he's
so so recently about a revolutionist
that he had witnessed in the past six
months and he said that this revolution
would take place either peacefully uh
Through The Ballot Box or through
Bloodshed it of course with his
preference that this is done
democratically peacefully and Through
The Ballot Box and it was only an hour
before he was shot in the leg that he
was affirming to me that he was
confident that this would not turn
violent but this really was about a
democratic Groundswell the people riding
this populist wave that they had faced
an investment that he will bring the
change and root out corruption in
Pakistan stabilizing economy because
this is a nation that's been struggling
deeply with economic roses concerning
people on its international monetary
fund debt and so he is still enjoying
despite being announced from his role
and convicted to himself of trading
State death he has actually enjoying the
great deal of support so he's his party
still controlled a great deal of the
provinces here in Pakistan
but this is a nation that has had a
history of deep fault lines there is a
strong role of the military a military
that in part helped him rise the power
that he had recently been deeply
critical uh of and I've been
interviewing uh the police chief of
islamabads just in the past couple of
days there they have barricaded the
heart of governments in the parliament
the president the prime ministers have
all barricaded police getting ready to
drop tear gas if indeed they needed to
their police chief there insisted to me
he wanted to give people the Democratic
right to protest but such as the
volatility of politics in this nation
and the Deep feeling there was thought
concern in recent days that this had the
propensity the potential at least to
turn and today we witnessed that
firsthand